When Donald Trump is consistent on something,
he's consistently inconsistent and the stock
market is a really good example of that.
You can always count on Donald Trump to brag
about how he's responsible for boosting the
stock market on days that the stock market
is up.
You can also count on Donald Trump to either
ignore the stock market altogether or if he
has to talk about it on a day when the stock
market is down.
Blame it on someone or something else.
Never him.
The stock market is very down.
Lately.
The Dow was down a thousand points on Monday,
900 or so points on Tuesday down a little
more on Wednesday.
And as of this recording right now, the Dow
is down another 500 points today.
This brings me no pleasure at uni.
You guys know, I mean, you know, Republicans
like to say left is cheering for a bad economy
despite Trump.
No, no.
You should've seen me looking at my mutual
fund account last night and it was bad.
It was really, really bad and it's getting
even uglier now.
So what does Donald Trump do?
He says, Oh, yet the stock market crashed
all week because of the democratic debate
on Tuesday night at 8:00 PM Eastern time,
hours after the stock market had already closed
on Tuesday.
Now remember the market tumbled on Monday,
but the democratic debate was Tuesday night.
The market tumbled on Tuesday, but the democratic
debate was on Tuesday night, our Trump's followers,
this stupid, or is he the one that's this
dumb.
Take a look at this.
Mr president, you mentioned the stock market
earlier.
To go back to that, to be clear, the Dow Jones
dropped more than 2000 points this week.
Are you suggesting that that was overblown?
Are financial markets overreacting here?
I think if financial markets are very upset
when they look at the Democrat candidates
standing on that stage, making fools out of
themselves and they say, if we had to have
a president like this, and there's always
a possibility, it's an election.
You know, who knows what happens, right?
I think we're going to win.
I think we're going to win by a lot, but when
they look at the statements made by the people
stand behind standing behind those podiums,
I think that has a huge effect.
Yeah.
Isn't that just stunning that a president
say this and that there is not complete repudiation
of the obvious absurdity of what Donald Trump
is saying?
Stocks crash Monday and a Fox news guy named
Charles Payne blamed it on Bernie winning
the Nevada caucus on Saturday.
Stocks crash Monday and Tuesday and Trump
blames it on an event that didn't happen until
after that, after stocks had closed for trading
those two days, the democratic debate took
place.
I don't know who falls for this stuff, but
somebody must, right, because otherwise Trump
wouldn't be able to get away with it.
And then Trump just keeps blaming other people.
During yesterday's press conference goes into
talking about Barack Obama, and remember this
is a press conference as we will later talk
about, about Corona virus and Trump is blaming
Democrats for the stock market crash caused
by Corona virus and now goes into talking
about Barack Obama.
But that is because he's kept interest rates.
President Obama didn't have near the numbers.
And yet if you look at what happened, he was
paying zero.
We're paying interest now it's more conservative
and frankly, people that put their money away
are now getting a return on their money as
opposed to not getting anything.
But I think, you know, we're the, we're the
greatest of them all.
We should be paying the lowest interest rates.
And when Germany and other countries are paying
negative rates, meaning they are literally
getting paid when they put out money.
I mean, they, they borrow money and they get
paid when he gets paid back.
Whoever heard of this before, it's a first,
but we don't do that.
So I totally disagree with our fed.
I think our fed has made a terrible mistake
and it would have made a big difference as
good as we've done, even without the 2000
points.
And we started off at 16,000 and we'll be
at 28,000 without, we're going to crack 30,000.
Uh, we have had increases like nobody's seen
before.
Uh, but we're doing well, but we have to watch,
uh, we're doing well anyway.
In other words, even despite the 2000 points,
it sounds like a lot and it's a lot, but it's
not.
It's very little compared to what we've gone
up.
Obama was bad.
Our fed is bad, even though it's run by the
person that he selected to run it.
Everybody's terrible.
Everything is to blame except for Donald Trump,
who is great and remember that even before
this 2000 plus point stock market, a tumble
Trump stock market was already underperforming.
Barack Obama's, those numbers are going to
become even more skewed in favor of Barack
Obama.
Thanks to this crash, which I hate and take
no pleasure in.
I want to be really clear about that because
we don't play those games on this show.
I'm not rooting for the stock market to crash.
I'm not rooting for the United States to fail.
Believe me, ask my girlfriend.
She knows what's going on with my investments
and this is very, very ugly.
No matter who is president, I don't want our
stock market to fail.
But blaming Bernie's win in Nevada and the
democratic debate and the fed give me a break.
Is Trump some kind of time traveler that things
that happen after the majority of the crash
are to blame for the crash?
It's horrifying that this is considered an
explanation from the president of the United
States or an analysis to many of Donald Trump's
followers.
It does not bode well for our country that
the president is even trying to save this
stuff.
Obviously.
Why does no one just say in the room, mr president,
the things you're naming happened after the
crash, not before.
How is it possible that they are causally
related?
It's like saying a snow storm that happened
two days after a power outage is to blame
for the power outage.
Well, how?
How is that possible?
How does that even make any remote sense?
And of course the bigger picture is that Trump
is part of the market crash, but it's really
larger fears of course about Corona virus
and we are not prepared to deal with it here
in the United States.
I really want to dig in more to this.
We had a lot of reaction to yesterday's interview
with dr Isaac, bogus about Corona virus and
we have Trump's press conference from yesterday.
He's putting Mike Pence in charge of Corona
virus.
The guy barely believes in science.
So we'll talk about all of that coming up
for now.
Let me know your thoughts on Trump's stock
market explanation.
I'm on twitter@deepak